in our morning rounds new research that
could slash the number of people getting
stents for bypass surgery for coronary
artery disease a study looked at more
than 5,000 people with blocked arteries
but without severe symptoms like extreme
pain or heart attack it found that
regularly taking medications along with
lifestyle changes was just as effective
as preventing at preventing heart
attacks and premature deaths as the more
invasive procedures those medications
include statins blood pressure drugs and
aspirin therapy our doctor Taran Rula is
a cardiologist at northwell health Terry
good morning good morning this is this
kind of blows my mind to be honest with
you why is this new research so
important this was really a blockbuster
trial that was just presented at the
American Heart Association meeting and
really hotly anticipated by
cardiologists so there are millions of
Americans who have angina which is chest
pain usually caused by a blocked
coronary artery many of them go on to
have a stress test and that stress test
will come back positive showing ischemia
or low blood flow to the heart muscle
and the question has really been in
those patients what do we do do we just
treat them with optimal medical therapy
things like statins and blood pressure
medicines and lifestyle changes or do we
do optimal medical therapy and send them
to the cath lab for potentially a stent
procedure to open the artery or bypass
surgery and we really didn't know the
answer we had had data from previous
years that had suggested what this child
showed which is that when you compare
these two groups and there was no
difference in terms of things like heart
attack or death over the course of
follow-up between the conservative group
of medical therapy and the invasive
group what the invasive group did have
in terms of a benefit was less angina
less symptoms and improved quality of
life so when you talk about making
patients feel better and live longer
this show that they may not live longer
with a stent or bypass surgery but they
will feel better potentially now this
trial only followed patients out on a
median of three point three years so we
definitely need a longer term follow-up
to see what happens at ten years and 15
years and 20 years do we get different
data at that at that point you have 1.8
million people getting stents every year
do you think this could decrease the
number of those type of operations that
we see I certainly think it's going to
make cardiologists potentially take
step back and also patients too and ask
the question do I fit the criteria of
this trial and should I really be going
on to get a stent or a catheterization
or bypass surgery and so it will make us
question it now there are certainly
patients who still will get stents those
with unstable angina where the chest
pain is really getting worse and worse
or more severe or they've had a heart
attack where they have very severe
disease and their arteries but for those
other patients certainly those who have
no symptoms there really may be no
benefit and if you have mild symptoms
and it's gonna be a shared
decision-making strategy where you talk
to your doctor and you say am i
optimized on my medical therapy my
statins my blood pressure medicines my
lifestyle or can I do better
yeah dr. Turner will thank you very much
Shane to shoot it all right thank you
doctor